Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Collin
from Oregon?
Collin, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hi.
Can you hear me OK?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Beautifully.
Speaker 2: Oh, thank you, wow, this is really
amazing.
I've never done anything like this.
Well, let's do it so well, I'm curious.
Usually you do this on Fridays.
How are you doing on a Wednesday?
What's going on?
Speaker 1: We always do it on Wednesday for
the Friday show.
Speaker 2: Oh, really?
Yeah.
Oh, I thought so, because I remember you,
I was watching you, you said, well, we do
this live.
So I was under the impression that you shoot
the shows the day that you post them.
Is that not
Speaker 1: true?
It's not true with the calls, because sometimes
we like extra time just in case we need to
in case they're really bad.
Like, for example, let's say this call didn't
go anywhere.
We would have time to, like, cut it and film
something else.
Speaker 2: Oh, sure, because I'm sure you
get some people maybe they call and they really
don't know what to say.
Speaker 1: Yeah, sometimes it happens.
Speaker 2: Well, it's funny because your nerves
act up because you're like, OK, I'm talking
with the radio person.
This person makes a whole career talking and
you're like, well, I listen to your show.
I'm actually a recent listener and you're
getting me into politics beautiful.
So I'm really kind of new at this.
But I do have a good question for you.
I hope it's a good question.
Good.
So the reason I don't watch a lot of conservative
news.
Well, I do watch it, but I just I feel like
the way they present information.
Is so aggressive.
Speaker 1: Yes, I completely when you said
when you said, I believe the way they present
information, I was thinking aggressive in
my mind.
And then you said it.
I agree.
And the thing is, a lot of people like that.
A lot of people like the idea that, hey, Trump's
a big man.
And Ben Shapiro talks quickly and Steven Crowder
wears a gun bra while he talks.
And so this is like, yeah, it doesn't even
matter what they say, it's how they're saying
it.
I 100 percent agree with you now.
Speaker 2: So let's talk about conservative
religion.
Now, you also talked about you are Jewish,
correct?
Speaker 1: Yeah, yes.
I'm ethnically Jewish and culturally Jewish.
I'm not religious.
Speaker 2: But so we talk about religious
ideology.
We talk about the praise and worship, the
high and mighty, the we give our souls.
And so I find a lot of conservative religious
ideas to be like, well, you don't need to
understand why.
You just believe, OK, right.
So maybe conservative tries to appeal to that
by being like you guys you got even Ted Cruz
was like for us to go against the wall, we
need to wake up.
And it's like, OK, I'm confused.
Speaker 1: I'm I'm confused as well.
But you are absolutely spot on that there
is this aggressive nature to the presentation
from a lot of these right wingers.
And for me, it's just I mean, it's like I
wouldn't be agreeing with them either way,
but I completely find it off putting.
But it's a feature, not a bug, for for many
on the right.
All right, Colin, thank you.
I appreciate the call.
That's all the time we have today.
So if I didn't get to you, consider this an
apology, but we will take phone calls again.
Thanks, everybody.
Quick break and then we'll be right bac